وثلاثين الامريكية امس خوي سبعة
وخمسين وايهما اقرب لان تمتلك
ارض الواقع. والان برأيكم
متابعينا ايهما اقوى اف خمسة
حوادث واثنين اخرين كانا للحلفاء
كوريا الجنوبية واليابان. برنامج
مقاتلات اف خمسة وثلاثين يواجه
نقصا في المحركات الاحتياطية
مائة وعشرة الى مائة واربعين
مليون دولار. لكن برغم القدرات
المسلحة الامريكية نحو سبعمائة
طائرة اف خمسة وثلاثين. لا
في حال حدوث مواجهة بين الطائرات
فان سوخوي سبعة وخمسين ستكتشف اف
كما انها صنعت مع احتساب حاجات
فنيي الصيانة. تمتلك القوات
اقوى مميزاتها انها قادرة على
تفادي صواريخ المضادات الارضية
لنكمل. تستطيع اف خمسة وثلاثين
التي صنعتها شركة لوكيد مارتن
ولكن لا نضمن ان تناور اف خمسة
وثلاثين امام منظومة اس خمسمائة
وستين درجة. يمكنها مقاتلة عدة
اهداف في وقت واحد وقصف عدة
المقاتلة قدرة استطلاع وجمع
معلومات للطيار بزاوية ثلاثمائة
كامل تقريبا عن الرادارات مدفعا
رشاشا عيار خمسة وعشرين ملليمترا
تنجح اسلحتها بالاصابة. يمكن
لاجهزة استشعارها ان تتعقب
قدرة فائقة على السرعة فوق صوتية
تتضمن كميات كبيرة من المواد
المركبة لتبقى متخفية كفاية
لاجبار خصومها من الجيل الخامس
المتحدة الامريكية. وهي ايضا
مقاتلة من الجيل الخامس تعرف
جاهزية هذا الطراز من المقاتلات
الذي يعد اكثر برامج الاسلحة
دولار خلال عشرة حوادث للطائرة.
كان لامريكا منها الاسد بثمانية
لم تدخل باي حرب واقعية عكس خوي
سبعة وخمسين التي خاضت حروبا على
البنتاجون مغناطيسا مستخدما في
محرك مقاتلة الشبح مصنوع من مواد
سوخوي سبعة وخمسين ثنائية المحرك
تقدر بنحو مائة مليون دولار.
الادخنة من الهدف المطلوب
استهدافه. وهنا يعلم العدو ان
ليس فقط باسلحة جو جو ولكن ايضا
باسلحة جو ارض فانها توفر مرونة
ولنا لقاء قريب يا سادة في بطولة
كأس الحرب العالمية الثالثة.
تشخيص الاعطال التي تطرأ عليها.
وطلب تصليحات او صيانة بشكل الي
تعد الامريكية اف خمسة وثلاثين
هي مفترس خفي كما يقول الخبراء.
ايضا ومشكلات اخرى تتعلق
بالصيانة. ما ادى الى خفض معدلات
الالكترونية. وهنا مهمة اخرى.
حرب الشبكة المركزية. تستطيع
معتمدة على تقنية متقدمة ليزرية.
يمكنها التعاون مع منظومة اس
سو سبعة وخمسين جاهزة ضد اي عدو.
كما انها عدو خطير محتمل في
كيلومتر لكل ساعة. وهنا يصرح
الخبراء العسكريون الامريكيون ان
ولا تشاركها. تحمل اف خمسة
وثلاثين التي تستطيع التخفي بشكل
وصاروخين من طراز ايه اي ام مئة
وعشرين سي جو جو لمحاربة
تكلفة في العالم. وبرغم هذه
الكوارث كلها فاف خمسة وثلاثين
الامر. وبين تحطم عند الهبوط
والتحطم في البحر وحريق بطائرة.
تسببت اف خمسة وثلاثين بخسارة ما
يقارب مليار وثلاثمائة مليون
بينما تعمل اف خمسة وثلاثين
بمحرك واحد ويبلغ سعرها ما بين
غير مصرح عنها من الصين. اوقف
عملية تصنيعها حتى يتأكد من
مواقع في وقت واحد ايضا ومن
مسافة بعيدة. بينما تظل واحدة من
تبيعها سوى لحلفائها. بين
المقاتلتين. الطائرة الروسية
تعمل بمحركين. تحتل حاوية
الاسلحة التي تتسع لما يبلغ وزنه
حاجة الى التخفي يمكن للطائرة ان
تحمل المزيد من الاسلحة في
سوخوي سبعة وخمسين من الجيل
الخامس هي مفترس مهاجم في حين
الروسية الا عندما نراها في ارض
الواقع. وقد يكون هذا قريبا.
الهائلة لاف خمسة وثلاثين فانها
ارتكبت اخطاء فادحة كلفت
الولايات متحدة الكثير من
الاموال. وبعد ان اكتشف
خمسة وثلاثين اسرع وتستخدم
السلاح قبلها وفق خبراء موسكو.
الروسية المتطورة كنظام الجوي
الاس ثلاثمائة والاس اربعمائة
دولار. بسرعة الف ومائتي ميل في
تحلق المقاتلة الاكثر شراسة في
الطائرات المعادية وقنبلتين
موجهتين من طراز جي بي يو واحد
العالم ما يجعلها تضمن ان
الولايات المتحدة تمتلك السماء
يبلغ وزن كل واحدة منهما نحو
تسعمائة كيلو جرام. توفر
وتستهدف طائرة قريبة من اي
اتجاه. يتم تزويد الطيار
ان واحد. تستطيع ضرب ستة عشر
هدفا دفعة واحدة في وقت واحد
الامريكي. المنافس الاول لسوخوي
سبعة وخمسين ياتي من الولايات
له من مجرم روسي مدمر. ويا لها
من قدرات خارقة. وحش الجو
خمسة وثلاثين وهي اكبر سنا من سو
سبعة وخمسين. لا تحتاج المقاتلة
تظهر في رادارات الخصوم الا في
حالة واحدة. عندما تتصاعد
بالمعلومات من خلال خوذته التي
تكلف وحدها مبلغ اربعمائة الف
طائرة سو سبعة وخمسين قد مرت من
هنا. فهي فائقة المناورة لديها
اف خمسة وثلاثين الى ان تكون
متوجهة بشكل مباشر الى هدفها حتى
كبيرة. هي مقاتلة خفية توصف
بانها قاتلة الرادارات. فهي لا
في باطنها من اجل التخفي. قوة سو
سبعة وخمسين لم تظهر بعد هي
اهدافا من مدى مائتي كيلو متر.
وتحمل اسلحتها من صواريخ وقنابل
لسو سبعة وخمسين. ليطلق عليها
الناتو اسم فيلون اي المجرم. فيا
راداريا يمكنها من اكتشاف
الاهداف الجوية والبرية
والبحرية. تتبادل المعلومات مع
مراكز القيادة ووحدات القتال
يمكنها من اداء مهام جميع انواع
طائرات القتالية. وكونها مجهزة
ام منها والدخول في معارك قريبة.
حيث تكون الافضلية في هذه الحالة
الفائقة على القيام بمناورات
جوية معقدة. هذه المقاتلة مزودة
قادرة على التحليق لمدة طويلة
بسرعة تفوق سرعة الصوت في النهار
سبعة اطنان في الحاويتين. بطول
اثنين وعشرين مترا يصل اقصى
بمجموعة متنوعة من الصواريخ
بعيدة المدى التي يمكنها ضرب عدة
اربعمائة للدفاع الجوي ايضا.
بينما تمتلك الطائرة نظاما
على بعد يزيد عن اربعمائة كيلو
متر. تقدر على تتبع ستين هدفا في
الى انها تحمل الصواريخ ار ام
سبعة وثلاثين. التي يمكن ان تقتل
قدرات هجومية هائلة لا نظير لها
بين منافسيها حتى الان. اضافة
والاسلحة الحديثة واحدث الاجهزة
الالكترونية. مهامها متعددة تبدأ
بالحرب الالكترونية لانها تمتلك
اوسع الامكانات في مجال الحرب
الاخرى لتزيد قدرتها على التعامل
مع العدو. سو سبعة وخمسين ليست
مجرد طائرة متعددة المهام انما
هي طائرة متعددة الاستخدامات. ما
رادارات سو سبعة وخمسين اكتشاف
الاهداف المطلوب التعامل معها من
السماء. لانها تجمع بين اربعة
عوامل مهمة التخفي والسرعة
ارتفاع لها نحو عشرين الف متر.
سرعتها القصوى الفين وستمائة
والليل وفي اي ظروف جوية. لها
قدرة عالية على حماية النفس. حيث
الحاوية الخارجية. وفي هذه
الحالة يمكن لها ان تحمل ما يزن
الفين وخمسمائة طن نحو ثلث حجم
الطائرة. وعندما لا تكون هناك
الذي يطوف سماء المعارك.
المقاتلة المتخفية سو سبعة
باندلاع حرب عالمية جديدة او
ربما صراع بين دولتين وخاصة في
العالم اثبات جدارتها وتفوقها
العسكري وسط التهديدات المستمرة
مرات. وصاروخ كنجال لديه القدرة
على حمل رؤوس نووية وتقليدية
الرادارات وبها احدث اجهزة
الملاحة والتوجيه والتصويب. يخطط
ويبلغ مداه اكثر من الفي كيلو
متر. امر ان تحقق سيمنح طائرة
جسمها المطلي يمتص الموجات
اللاسلكية ويجعلها تتخفى عن
الروس لتزويد سبعة وخمسين التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت عشر
الصناعات العسكرية. ليتمخض هذا
الاصرار على التفوق بصناعة اقوى
الامريكية لمن ستكون الغلبة?
وماذا لو تواجهت الطائرتين في
مئات الكيلو مترات بين سبعة
وخمسين الروسية واف خمسة وثلاثين
اهداف في عمق اراضي العدو من
مسافات شاسعة. تحلق سو سبعة
وخمسين بسرعة تفوق سرعة الصوت.
تتوزع كل اسلحتها داخل هيكلها.
وخمسين من بين الافضل في العالم
ان لم تكن الافضل بسبب قدرتها
اشرس وحوش الجو واشدها فتكا
بالاهداف. مفترسات الجو المرعبة.
الامريكية وروسيا الاتحادية اقوى
دولتين على هذا الكوكب. وباقوى
واشرس المقاتلات في العالم.
ولنبدأ به المجرم الروسي. الشبح
الجو في العقود القادمة.
الجو ايهما ستكون المنتصر? حاولت
العديد من الدول العظمى في
الاسلحة الجوية في العالم. سو
سبعة وخمسين واف خمسة وثلاثين
مقاتلات بسرعة البرق وقدرة كبيرة
على التخفي امام اقوى الانظمة
الرادارية. بمواصفات واسلحة
خارقة تدمر خصومها من مسافات
خارقة وضربات لا ترد. ها هم في
الجو يتنافسون. الولايات المتحدة